are you ready to hop into hard Stone's  next expansion you don't have long to  wait I'm Tony and this game spot news  update is working with a full deck mean  streets of gadgets and launches Thursday  December first this expansion brings 132  new cards to the game plus the new grimy  goon cabal and Jade Lotus factions a  number of the new cards belong to one of  these groups so you'll have to choose a  side in order to play their cards some  of the crazier new ones will let you  uncover cards in the deck he'll your  minions and even shoot piranhas at your  opponents you can pre-order mean streets  of gadgets and card packs now battlenet  is offering 50 packs for 50 bucks though  you won't be able to actually open your  packs until launch day but hey at least  they guarantee at least one rare card in  each pack to keep up with all the latest  hearthstone news you're already in the  right place  you